were killed if they are killed they die
Shah when they die they go to the
Hellfire they burn in there for
eternity that's the
difference Allah says in
Quran is there any rest bite for us or
is there any result for us except for
the two good things two good things
either Victory or sh
how can you lose they the the biggest
winners in the world today are the
people in Gaza because they're in
between two things Victory and
martydom and the biggest losers in the
world today are those Israeli zionists
who are killing those people because
they are being exposed as the most
dishonorable and cowardly people I've
ever read about with a 100 to1 ratio of
combatant to non-combatant death how
could it be that Hamas is killing more
IDF than the IDF is killing Hamas and to
get your anger out you're killing the
children according to the IDF figures
Hamas has killed more of them I the IDF
than H they've killed Hamas
how that means you don't want to
fight that means you're a
coward that's what it means
Allah is exposing the
cowardice and showing us what you're
really about you get angry you kill a
child there's never been a war in
history that has been won by killing
women and
children let that sink in for a second
there's never been a war in history that
has been won on killing Women and
Children You Can't Win Wars by killing
women and children and they're killing
them and killing them and killing them
let's be real about this for a second
how much of the population are they
killing not even
1% it will take them 10 years to rebuild
the population even more so you even
that is a weak strategy because you
killed 12,000 of them they're
Palestinian women
mashallah they have a three four kids
five kids six kids seven just to because
of anger just to show the
enemy so actually the population is
increasing so it's a failed strategy you
destroy some buildings you think you're
winning a war by destroying buildings
and killing children you're losing the
war you losing everything you're losing
credibility in front of the
International Community that's what's
happening and instead they're getting
killed they're running away from their
friends I saw a particular video with
one IDF he was sitting down saying I
don't want to go I don't want to
go
come
I don't want to go I don't want to
go but you want to be on a plane and
press the
button W he's worse than a
coward he's worse than all of
this and Allah is exposing even within
the um the rotten
elements isn't he and that's one of the
and the
wisdoms
that Allah is
distinguishing the impure from the pure
and he is accumulating and aggregating
the pure things
together and then he'll put it all into
the Hellfire and they all losers that's
the Quran that's what the Quran says so
we are starting to see this guy here
this Muslim over there this one over
there he's a traitor of the cause he's
he's a treacherous person he's against
the
Palestinians this m this issue has shown
us who's with us and shown us who's
against
us even among the non-muslims we have
started to see some of the true colors
of those
individuals huh we have started to see
it it's an x-ray it's an MRI we're try
to see everything
now you you can't say this and what you
ah which means if my child if your child
if our children were killed in front of
those people they would be walking in
nonchalant and indifference and apathy
they would not
care now I know
you because not all Muslims are the same
now we're able to do Tas
categorization of this non Muslim is a
hostile one and this non Muslim here is
a good one and this Muslim here is a
good one and this one here is a bad one
it's an x-ray machine
it's an x-ray it's an
MRI this is the
Quran this is what happens when there's
a Calamity there's always good in
it there's always good in the Calamity
because we start to see everything
everything is clear and haven't you
noticed that the Muslims are more united
now than ever
before that's something I I think is one
of the greatest things that have come
from this situation that the Muslims
have become more united now than ever
before there's one obstacle between us
and victory and you know what the
obstacle is
unification that's the
obstacle we have 59 Muslim majority
countries we don't even need all of them
to unite together if five of them United
together you'd have another superpower
six look at the size of Pakistan 20 what
is it 30 million 260 I don't know what
it is 280 million it's unbelievable it's
almost the size of America America is
million you put Pakistan and Indonesia
together that's it with turkey and Egypt
it's
finished it's
done they would never like that to
happen put five or six of these
countries now I know you're thinking
about the political this and that I'm
just saying it's possible because at the
end of the
day it's not the politicians who make up
the countries it's the people who make
up the countries and if you push
up and if you push the people too much
they will remove anyone that needs to be
removed or they will change and push
anyone that needs to be changed and push
that's what going
happen between us
and victory is
unification Unity of the Muslim people
all we need to do is become one body
again that the Muslim to the other
Muslim is like one body like one
building it pulls itself
together so Allah has taken from us sh
Allah has brought us closer to him
Allah has reminded us of death Allah has
purified the people of Gaz and he's
purified us Allah has shown us who's our
enemy where the hostilities are and who
is not our enemy Allah has brought us
together Allah has strengthen our
resolve Through This
calamity if Israel didn't
exist and the Zionist didn't do what we
were doing we'd be killing each other
even more
there's always good and
bad you can hate something but it can be
good for you and Allah knows and you
don't
know